when I have a community of people who
are weaponizing mentally ill women to
try to destroy my life in court.
>> Do you think that people could earnestly
hate you for the way that you've
conducted yourself on the internet for
the past 3 to 5 years?
>> That has nothing to do with this. I'm
not answering.
>> Yeah, there are people who are laughing
at Connor standing up to you cuz you're
acting like a petty, childish tyrant.
>> So, so hold on. You think JTOK, Queman,
esports Batman, they all hate you for
delusional or non-serious reasons?
>> Yes. Uh, I
it's a it's a great day today. Oh my
god. So, if you guys missed it, Counter
Points had a stream today and he was
talking to Doobie and then I think
eventually Destiny hops on and dude it
goes it goes pretty crazy. There's a lot
of fighting back and forth and Dubie
will make a point of okay well when Desi
doxes people he's putting people's
family at risks and he's like creating
what we would call a permission
structure or a a possible lens by which
people will judge him and act against
him right that while we principally
don't
he is sort of losing his moral high
ground to say people should defend me
against these these kinds of actions
right I like I still am very vehement we
don't stoop to that level we don't try
to invoke real world harm on people we
don't do anything like that right And
this idea, this concept of like
describing what Destiny's outlook
sort of sews for him. Destiny describes
this as Dubbie trying to log his child.
That's how he will describe it to
people, right? And now Connor finally
like calls him out on this today and the
crash out is crazy. that like I'm
talking pages and pages and pages of all
caps logs spamming repeatedly over and
over again about like like about Connor,
how Connor's a loser. So, as a result,
Destiny's posted this today. Right here
is the the big paragraph that we're
going to focus on today. Okay. So, as of
today, I do not want anything to do with
Connor/Counter Points. I will not
appear. Didn't even spell his first name
right. One end man. Like this guy
doesn't even know the people he claims
are his friends. Didn't know Erdite's
degree. Doesn't know how to spell
Connor<unk>'s name. Like it's just
little things like that that really sort
of drive home how much he considers
other people. And it's just it's wild.
Anyway, I will not appear on any panels
or shows with him. I will enforce my
copyright against him if he is reacting
to my content in a non-transformative
way. Dude, that's crazy to be like, I'm
actually going to sue Connor. I'm going
to DMCA Connor. I'm going to DMCA him.
This is This is the funniest thing to
me, man. L M AO. I have zero knights,
zero defenders, zero people besides food
shops who can actually put up a
non-cocked argument. It's actually
insane. It's like, why is nobody
articulate or intelligent defending me?
This this perplexes me. Why would nobody
want to defend me? Why did all the
intelligent people I used to hang out
with go away and now nobody intelligent
will defend me? Why is it that only some
total zombie will defend me? Hm.
It must be Jay- Sock's fault. It must be
Dubbiey's fault. It must be the
Starker's fault. It must be everyone
else's fault. It couldn't possibly be my
fault. That could that doesn't make any
sense, guys. It couldn't be my fault.
It's everyone else's fault.
I have no defenders.
Here we go.
>> My uh my chief mod. So uh what Destiny
what I started this morning's stream
with is uh the reasonable ask that I
heard you articulate that I'm okay with
is do not allow snarkers in your
community to endlessly talk about me or
why I'm no longer associate fraternizer.
So if I were to go around and ask there
has not a single time in the past six
months been a one plus hour voice call
with you being here talking about or
anything.
>> Let's try to play nice just so we can
get through the substance and then if we
want to be mean after the substance then
we can be mean after the substance. Um
to my
>> you seen here at all? I think he's seen
here and I've never been a subject to
that conversation as people never been a
thing that he's nobody's ever been here
for instance I've been brought up and
>> well the issue is if if there's a bunch
of people who like DGG in Conor's
community or if they're DJers in
Connor's community they're going to
press Dubie about it cuz you've made a
huge thing about Doobie is Dubbie
supposed to just say no I can't talk
about that no sorry I cannot invoke
Destiny I cannot invoke Stephen Destiny
Bennell in any other Discord what is he
supposed to do
to's
a little bit. I'm asking you, Connor,
slow to ask your server. When I do a
pole at your server, none of these
people would say, "Oh, no, no, no. We've
never heard somebody say, "Quick, grab
Dubbie." Destiny is the topic of the
conversation for Doobie to come in and
do all of the ordinary smears. Right.
>> I would I would I would appreciate a 30
second stance.
>> Why would that not be expected? That's
literally every Discord. Hey, someone's
here on one side of the issue and we
need our expert on the other side of the
issue. That's every single Discord ever.
If Doomie knows like a bunch of these
arguments and people like know that he
knows it and knows that know that he
argues it like this is what will happen
if let's say someone's arguing on a
point right and they've heard it from
somebody else and they can't argue the
point perfectly they'll go oh I'll go
grab this guy who's who I've heard argue
it he knows the point
>> answer to my knowledge the answer is no
the people that I would ask if this had
ever happened in the past 6 months are
Tae uh who's my former editor and former
chief modellrunner who's my current
chief mod and I would ask them if they'd
ever seen anything like that.
>> Okay.
>> Can you drag one of them in here and ask
him?
>> Yeah, sure. Uh Fel was on here 30.
>> You think Destiny knows he could just
ignore the Starkers? No, he doesn't know
this. He doesn't know this. He doesn't
care. He is fully invested in getting
Dubbie to stop from talking in like 20
person VCs about that he's about how
he's a bad person. And by the way, I
guarantee you Doobie doesn't go in and
just bring this stuff up all the time. I
guarantee you people bring it up to
Doobie as often as he brings it up. At
least
>> seconds ago. Um, do you
>> basically because Wick is like a joint
space, right? And Dubbiey's like sitting
there, people will join just to press
Dubbie on this stuff and that's not his
fault. Hold on real quick. Um, before I
create like another chat, I suppose um I
just want to ask a quick question. Um,
Destiny, do you have anything that you
want to say to Dubbie or you want uh
feedback from Dubbie on? And Doobie, do
you have anything that you want to say
to Destiny or give him feedback on?
Because if you guys don't have
>> I would have a mutual one-on-one. Duby's
goal is to destroy my life. Conor,
you're [__] [__] That was the
dumbest question you've ever asked in
your entire entire life.
>> These people these people who just won't
lay down when I threaten them. They're
trying to destroy my life. Oh yeah. What
are they saying? Well, they're talking
about me shine without consent. Well,
you admitted to that. They're trying to
destroy my life.
>> Do you have anything that you want to
talk to him about? Yes or no?
>> Well, I mean, we can I mean, we can run
this we can run this one thing. Did you
do you find his arguments for why uh
it's acceptable to my and his mom who
live in a separate state from me? Do you
find those arguments compelling
>> as a description?
Yes. The point Duby is making again I'll
just remind everybody the point Duby is
making is that if you operate on
Destiny's level of morality that would
be okay to dox people around him because
that is what Destiny does. That is the
description of the world Destiny has
created for himself right and the people
who defend him. that that basically by
defending his actions you are buying
into that kind of morality. That is the
whole point. How the is Destiny
pretending he doesn't understand this?
What is wrong with this guy? It's so
obvious, man.
>> Yes. So, you think that if you dox a
person, then it is the equivalent to dox
the other person's every single
unrelated family member because the one
person who got doxed might have a family
member that lives with them?
>> No, that's not that's literally not the
argument at all.
>> Yeah, sure. Let me go ahead and ask you
a question. But can I just wanted to
hear that I just want to hear that's
okay.
>> Can I kick you so Destiny and I can just
have
>> I don't know. I don't know why Connor I
don't know why Connor said yes to that.
That's not what Conor's saying. He's not
saying it is you you can do that now.
He's saying that Destiny if you meet a
character who is who is the same
morality as you. You are by by doxing
people and by doxing the adjacent of
people you don't like, you are invoking
some harm back on yourself by
threatening to dox the people around the
people you dislike. Right. You are
invoking the possibility of harm. You
are creating that possibility within
your own framework. It's so not
confusing.
>> No, no, no. I don't have that
conversation. I don't give a honestly.
Um the second question
>> I give a second the second
>> I give a because I think hold on hold on
hold on. If we are I know the I know the
thumbnail was a meme, but I I think that
this situation is actually quite serious
and you are thinking about like complete
disassociation for me and Wick. So
>> this is not a serious conversation. I'm
not I want Hang on. I'm sorry. I'm being
honest. Like that's that opinion is so
immediately stupid. I'm not even going
to pretend to have a conversation with
you unless um all the financial
stupid [__] opinion.
>> Um hold on. Wait there because there
were like two other things related to
Oh, [__]
>> No, wait. Wait. If you're if you just
let this guy
>> Conor does not like this. Okay. Connor
is not having a good time. You're to cut
me off. I'M YOUR FRIEND.
>> YOU JUST LET THIS GUY TALK un
unchallenged for four hours. Apparently,
you're doing talking the same racist as
my community and now he gets to leave
right away because you want me to call
him back. I'll literally CALL HIM BACK.
BUT I'LL tell you what I'm not going to
do. I'll I'll literally call him back in
the next 30 seconds. I'll bring Fel on
in order to ask the exact questions what
you want to ask. But what I'm not going
to do, and I'll tell you right now, is
I'm not going to have you say that after
you and I have had a five going on
six-year relationship that you get to
deem a topic undeserving of your time,
attention, or conversation. That's not
happening. So, so if you want to have a
conversation about whether or not doxing
an individual is equivalent to doxing
their family, we can have that
conversation. If you want to talk to
Duby, we can TALK TO DUBY.
>> DO IT. Do it real quick. Dude, write it
down. Go ahead.
>> So, okay. So, if I get doxed, my name,
phone number, and address are located.
How hard do you think it is to find my
extended family members?
>> Well, I don't know. Depends on where
they live. Could be
>> [__] It's in it's sometimes it's as
easy as a white pages or yellow pages
Google search. So now I have to wonder
whether or not you're because you didn't
even want to talk about this topic. Now
that
>> like you're obviously putting other
people at risk when you dock somebody,
Destiny. Yes or no? And he's just going
he's basically I don't know. I don't
know. It depends. I don't know. I don't
know. It depends.
>> We're talking about it and I ask you a
pretty simple and direct question.
You're saying I don't know. I think you
know
>> the problem. No. No. The problem Connor
the reason why this is the most topic in
the world is because you're talking
about using theoretical collateral
damage to make a direct target of
somebody else's family member. Do you
know if any No. No. No.
In fact, everybody says that would be
wrong.
You are opening other people's families
up to risk that was not there before.
That is the wrong that you're doing.
That is the that is what you are saying
is morally justified to go after
somebody. And Connor is saying, well, if
you're going to open up other people's
family members to risk, you understand
that you are doing the same to your own
family, right? that there will be
somebody who is the same kind of monster
you are and they will operate on that
same level of principle and maybe that's
just through going after you and you
know the risk is you know if your family
is around but maybe that's going after
other people too because they see the
risk that you're opening them up to
right like if you were to go after let's
say Dubie he's got a family he's got a
wife and kids that you if you go after
him you are going after his adjacent
you are you just are
do you understand that Somebody is going
to have the same level of belief that I
should open up everybody, right?
Somebody hypothetically, not me,
hypothetically, somebody will see it the
same way that I can open up your people
to the same risk that you just opened up
mine to that that is the risk you are
incurring when you engage in this
behavior.
>> Even people that I even have family
members that live with them or even have
children at all?
>> No, I don't. But at the same time, I
think it's a logical
>> infence. HOLD ON. WAIT, WAIT, WAIT. But
Doobie is running around here dozens of
times making these arguments in these
weird whatever the six hour. Doobie has
a family and you threaten to him on all
these servers arguing that my kid and
his
>> so not dude it's not even confusing.
Dubbie has a family. Destiny threatened
to Doobie that Destiny has said multiple
times, give me Dubbie's information. I
will publish it as soon as I can. Are
you out of your mind? Oh, but I didn't
yet. Okay, but you want to? Yes, he will
literally admit he wants to.
He will literally admit this and then
he's going, "But nobody nobody even has
a family." BRO, HOW WOULD YOU EVEN KNOW?
logical inference.
>> HOLD ON. WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT. BUT
Doobie is running around here dozens of
times making these arguments in these
weird whatever the six hour VCs on all
these servers arguing that my kid and
his mom are fair game. You crazy cotter.
>> Sure. Let's go ahead and address that.
So let's say hypothetically, well
actually no, we don't even have to treat
it as a hypothetical. We could treat
this as a real thing.
>> Let's talk about There you go. Yes.
>> Yeah. Let's talk about real things. So
Dubbie does have a family.
>> Have you called for his docs in the
past?
>> Oh, Connor's just got it exact. Yeah,
Desi's Desi is completely It's over.
It's over. WHY DOES HE EVEN ARGUE THIS?
Does he not understand? Does he just
have no remembrance, no recollection of
the things he said and done? Is he just
operating like without his brain,
without any long-term memory? Brother,
what the are you talking about? You
threatened to do somebody with a family.
You have said and doubled down multiple
times. If somebody gets me this guy's
information, I will publish it
immediately.
Well, do whatever the six hour VCs on
all these servers arguing that my kid
and his mom are fair game gambit. You
crazy.
>> Sure. Let's go ahead and address that.
So, let's say hypothetically, well,
actually, we don't even have to treat it
as a hypothetical. We can treat this as
a real thing.
>> Let's talk about There you go. Yes.
>> Yeah. Let's talk about real things. So,
Dubbie does have a family.
>> Have you called for his Excuse me.
>> Dy has not been doxed.
>> Have you called for his dogs in the
past? I'm pretty sure we had a
conversation about it in person.
>> I'm trying to find it. Yeah, but I don't
have it.
>> Okay. So if you had found it, would you
have published it?
>> Almost certainly yes.
>> Okay.
>> Absolutely.
>> He has a family. So his argument is you
don't know what's going on in people's
lives and when you expose their PII, you
don't know if most of the time it's
going to be fine, but you don't know
whether or not you're going to put them
in direct harm. Correct.
>> I mean, that's kind of the point of DXY.
Yeah.
>> Dude, can you hear my hand hit my
forehead? Can you hear my hand hit my
forehead when he does this?
Yeah. Yeah. That's kind of like the
point. I want them to feel threatened.
>> Yeah. No.
>> Right. So, if Dubie was, we're not even
engaging in hypotheticals. We're
engaging in a real example. So, if you
had Docs Doobie, let's say you just
found his PII, you publish it to the
internet. And let's say that he is the
internet vigilante that he claims to be
and then Adam off and finds his house
and kills him and his family. Aren't you
partially responsible for that behavior?
>> You possibly could be, but you think,
dude, what?
>> You possibly maybe could be hypothetic.
you would be partially respons
responsible. What your part is like
nobody's arguing that it's like okay to
go after you but you've created an
attenuated risk. Somebody could create
that same attenuated risk back on you or
your family. That is that is the thing
you're signing up for ask.
You don't have to talk to me about this.
This has been my life for the last year.
You Okay, hold on. So, shut the up.
Let's say that I were to find uh
Doobie's information and then I found
the information of his kid and I started
posting his. Do you think that's the
same thing? No. Thank you. Then you
agree with me. Then move on to another
topic. This is No.
LET'S GO, CONNOR. JUST MOVE ON TO
another topic. I know I totally wrecked
on this one. No. No. How about No. How
about we keep talking about this one
where you're being a total psychopath?
>> I won't because it's quite clear. So
let's say let's say that you had posted
his PII and then he'd gotten and his
dogs had gotten shot or his kids had
gotten injured in the thing. You're
partially responsible. Yeah.
>> Sure.
>> And then
Conor Conor,
>> you are signing up for at minimum the
same attenuated risk and that is
assuming that you haven't you've
basically done a like a stepwise you've
jumped to a different level of
escalation entirely. You're hoping that
you don't have other people around you
that will jump to a higher escalation
too, right? But you you are opening up
everybody around you to the same
attenuated risk, the same level of
conduct back towards you and the people
around you. Yes, that's what you're
doing.
>> It's still not the same as boasting his
children's
>> I don't think that's even the argument
that he made.
>> That is the argument he's saying that my
it is okay to a log my minor child and
that it would be fine to post my clip or
you have somebody that could give me
that.
>> He didn't say this at all. By the way,
all of this is wrong. Like Destiny is
totally skipping the part where we all
think he is an immoral psychopath,
right? Literally, everybody thinks
you're an immoral psychopath. We're
we're just explaining to you the risk
you're opening up you and your loved
ones to. That's we're explaining the
risk you're signing up for, not what we
think should happen. We all think you're
an immoral psychopath who is like
crashing the out. That's what's going on
here, Destiny. We all think you're
losing your mind. Do you understand? Do
you even remotely understand what's
going on? clip.
>> Bring him in here. He'll argue it.
>> Okay.
>> I don't think Doobie is going to argue
it, guys. I'm pretty sure Doobie is not
going to argue.
>> We understand because seriously, some DG
Chatters were some of the dumbest who
jumped
>> DG Chatters or DG Conor.
>> What?
>> I told you he's going to be I told you
we went through that whole thing before
cuz he's going to see about Connor
saying maybe Connor said before maybe
DGers are Indians. Maybe English is
their second language. Maybe they just
don't get it. And Pest is like seeing
snarkers everywhere. He's seeing
snarkers everywhere. Is it DG or Connor?
>> I'm not anti-Indian.
>> Okay. Butter butter chicken.
>> Are you with us?
>> I'm here. Dude, did you say that it was
acceptable to a log my son and use and
save the information until he's an adult
to send it to somebody later on and the
goal of getting him fired from a job or
kicked out of school?
>> No, I said the opposite.
>> What did you say?
>> Okay, so I'll just lay it out for you,
right? You can tell me why you disagree
with us.
>> You got you got to make him answer
faster, bro. I don't because he's going
to say
>> it's descriptive. Steven, you used to be
the master. Don't tell me to force him
to answer the question and then tell me
to shut up. That doesn't make sense.
>> I'm losing my mind. It's all good. Don't
worry. I just woke up for my dude.
>> You don't have anything else to do. Are
you going to go a chick?
>> I have a million other things to do. And
up and begging a tick would be
infinitely more entertaining than
listening to the same guy that was
slobbering and crying about food trucks
being hosted by my stream at night. Make
justification why guys who are spending
hours every day. WHY THEY DO MY [__]
SLEEP? WHY they should BE ALLOWED
STEVEN? THAT'S A NORMAL OPINION. IT'S A
NORMAL OPINION.
>> Oh my god. This guy's being mentally
abused by your ass and he's crashing out
now. No way.
>> Mentally abused.
>> This guy's This guy's like said he he's
tried to dox me. He's like advocated for
my death. By the way, just as like
another thing. And I would never say he
can't do this. I would never say you
have to like ban him from the internet
for it. But he also thought he found
like my dad's obituary and laughed at me
for my dad dying of cancer because he
thought that happened. It's like like I
don't I I'm sorry if I were doing this.
If that's all I was doing, you wouldn't
really be able to call me out while
being a fan of his and up and begging
would be infinitely more entertaining
than listening to the same guy that was
slobbering and crying about food shops
being hosted by my stream at night. They
justification why guys who are spending
hours every day.
WHY THEY ALLOW PEOPLE?
THAT'S a normal opinion. It's
>> you don't even LIKE FOOD SHOPS. LIKE my
now. Like my friend now, Connor. Why
would you like my friend? It's so up.
Just like my FRIEND NOW.
>> DO NOT WANT to hang OUT WITH HERE. I
DON'T HANG OUT WITH THESE PEOPLE AND
DIES HERE BEGGING GIRLS.
>> You hang out with food shops ALL THE
TIME. WHAT
>> girls and DMs
MOTHER
FOR SIX YEARS.
>> Let him do the next one. You what? You
hung out with Doobie the same as me for
six years. Just don't tell me you don't
hang out with these. That's a lie. I'm
not a pedoph.
The entire goddamn panel scene where I
met you too, by the way.
>> Out of here.
>> I'm sorry. Are we saying hang out is
when on panels together? In that case,
fine. I guess I hang out with Vivian.
>> Friendship was based off of panels for
the first three years of our friendship.
you. So yeah, don't get all dismissive
about the
everything you're saying is the most you
think that the friendship that we have
right now is THE SAME.
>> NO, IT'S NOT. YOU'RE JUST pissed off and
you know a BUNCH OF SICK FANS GOING TO
YOU OFF and I'm not going to do it.
>> Sick of my sick offense. You're so how
many dy I'm curious dy if YOU HAD TO
GUESS HOW MANY SIDES SPLINTER DISCORDS
can open right now that are cheering on
Connor for standing up to the evil
horrible terrible destiny. How many open
right now?
>> Stand up. Yeah, you're acting like a
total tyrant right now. Yeah, there are
people who are laughing at Connor
standing up to you because you are
acting like a petty, childish tyrant.
You're a loser. Yes, lots of people are
laughing at you. Act like a complete
loser. Yeah, obviously, dude. Are you
serious? Are you serious?
How many people are like laughing at my
crash out right now? Lots. Like a whole
lot. Like a ton of people are laughing
at your crash out explicitly right now.
I to I don't know what else to tell you,
man. I'm not I'm not going to pretend
otherwise. I laughed at this. I watched
this whole thing. I watched this scene
earlier today and laughed about it in my
Discord and now I'm watching it on
stream. This is my second run through
and it's still funny. So, I know Die, go
ahead and justify why you can a log my
15-year-old kid. Go.
>> Yes, please.
>> Okay, so I'll lay it out for you again
like I to Connor. So, there are lots of
crazy people online. When you encourage
doxing of other people in the space, you
don't know what the who who you're
talking to, right? There could be some
lunatic in your community that sees me
and thinks that sees me, think, believes
everything they say about me, thinks
that I'm trying to take you down and
thinks it's justified to attack me
physically, to attack my family
physically. There could be people that I
have unrelated uh beef with, right? And
I do that might say, "Hey, do we have
address now? Let's go." So, I'm not
saying that you personally would be uh
my son, but you me, given that I live
with my son, would put my entire family
at risk. That is just a reality. I'm not
saying it's a good thing. I don't accept
it. I would not do that to you or your
son ever. I would never support that
ever. What I'm telling you is you need
to stop creating this environment.
>> Yes. The best way to explain this is you
are an amoral psycho creating a world
that you deserve and we all want you to
stop cuz we're getting caught in the
crossfire. You're a totally unprincipled
amoral psycho. Please stop. Please just
even if you are even if you are this
way, just stop advertising it and
forcing everybody else to get caught in
the crossfire here. That's all you got
to do. LIKE TAKE ONE STEP BACK and stop
being a total piece of
>> where that's going to be normalized.
>> Just curious, Connor, did you hear an
explanation there or is that
>> I did and I've been linked clips where
people have said his description like
what he's saying right now is a lie and
then when I get linked the clips he's
saying the exact same thing.
>> If you want to show him being a liar,
give me the clip. I would love it.
>> What he has said is that right now based
on the rules that I've created, a
logging my child would be fair game.
Right. Die.
>> Correct. Because you put his child at
risk.
>> Okay. So, the more these are morally
equivalent actions in your eyes is a
15-year-old child until they're 18 to
burn in whatever you managed to collect
to their future employer, whatever. That
is the morally equivalent. They're
they're well, I wouldn't say those are
morally equivalent. I'm sure Duby would
feel they're morally equivalent if you
doxed him,
right? But they're not. They're not
necessarily morally equivalent. It's
that you are creating that thing. You
are creating an attenuated risk. And
one, when you create that risk, when you
do that jump in escalation to a new tier
of behavior, you are hoping that
everybody else sees the attenuated risk
you see and only goes as far as you
think you you went. But they might not
see it that way. You're opening them up
to totally crazy from people who don't
have a solid head on their shoulders,
right? In a way they weren't opened up
before. And that you're opening
Pandora's box. So stop for the sake of
everybody. Stop action. Stop posting the
name and address of somebody and then
maybe having family members live with
them. These are two things are morally
equivalent to you.
>> If you are risking his child of
homicide, why wouldn't he be allowed to
a log in your child?
>> Okay. So then just to be clear,
I AGREE WITH YOU. I AGREE WITH YOU. NO.
OKAY. I agree with you. It's fair game
right now. If I find the of any of
Doobie's family members, it's fair game
for me to post them, right?
>> Has he you?
>> No. But he's made the argument that's
fair game to go for Wait. No. Oh my god.
Destiny. Destiny, very important
question. If you see the any clip from
day from today, answer this one
question. How would you feel if you
didn't have breakfast this morning?
Destiny. Destiny. Destiny.
We need to make sure that we could still
answer this question. Are you capable?
Do you have the head on your shoulders
to answer this question still? I'm not
convinced, bro.
>> For my family, so I should be able
>> descriptive or prescriptive.
>> I'm being descriptive. I'm just saying
it would be right. Like he wouldn't be
able to complain about it. defectively.
Hold on. I know.
>> I know you know this, which is why this
conversation is so frustrating.
>> I'm describing because you No, no.
You've talked about tit for tat. You've
talked about eye for an eye.
>> I'm describing right now, Conor. I'm
only describing.
>> Excuse me.
>> I'm only describing.
>> I didn't say I would do it. I didn't say
I should do it. I'm just saying that if
I did, you wouldn't be able to complain
about it.
>> You don't think that's a substantive
difference?
>> I never said I should do it. I'm just
saying he wouldn't be able to complain
about it. Like, I could do it and I
would have justification for that. I
don't think I should. So, hold on. Hold
on. Let's just agree. Stop talking.
>> Oh my god.
>> So, if Doobie doxed you first and he put
your child at risk,
>> I'm just I'm just describing. I'm just
describing. Dude, the the tactics are so
bad when they're like removed from the
clapping seals. The tactics are
terrible.
>> Based off of an eye for an eye morality,
>> you would be entitled to doxing his
family and putting his family at risk.
That's descriptively true. where the
description that Doobie was making, the
description that Dubbie was making was
that some crazy person might find it to
do something horrible to his family and
blah blah blah blah blah. My argument
would be some crazy person, and by crazy
person, I mean the people that are
alreadying harassing me and calling on
my family members, they might see Duby's
argument and go, "Oh, Duby's actually
spitting fire here. We should actually
try to family." I have way more evidence
on my side for this.
Okay.
>> So, Destiny acting like a total
psychopath and basically taunting his
own Kiwi Farms thread is everybody
else's problem. And when you criticize
him, when you point out that he's doing
harmful behaviors, when you point out
that he's hurt a bunch of people and has
never taken accountability or
responsibility for his harmful actions,
that is apparently endorsing those
people's actions. Apparently, that's
like what he's trying to convince you
that because he won't stop taunting
total schizophrenics on the internet
that now nobody could criticize him.
They're actually going to do harm to him
by criticizing him, by using speech.
Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. That's fine.
What's the next
describe something inaccurately declare
victory and walk away?
>> That's not what you mean.
>> What am I describing? Dubie is making a
description. You're justify
this directly. Answer this directly. I
want you to answer this directly.
>> Yeah. If if Doobie doxed you and put
your child at risk, would you not be
descriptively entitled to doxing him and
putting his children at risk?
>> The goal of doxing without putting their
children. If that happens, it's
collateral. If somebody dox them, yeah,
sure.
>> Don't Okay. So, the answer is yes.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, you put his family at risk. So
descriptively, he's saying, "You are
creating a world in which it is okay for
him to do the same to you, but he's not
going to. He doesn't have to. He's out
here in Discords doing the equivalent of
calling for it." When you're out here
saying Destiny wouldn't be able to
complain if people doxed his whole
family because he's created the world
for it and that's the world we live in
now. That's the argument he's making. if
he's going to say that there's a chance
that a crazy um by the way this is the
same argumentation they have to use
against Hassan on some of the like left
like left-leaning pipeline stuff some of
the extremist stuff they do the same
thing Connor will engage in the same
behavior with Hassan and he's not
willing to call it out there like he
will do the same thing when Hassan
describes how hey actually like if
people come and watch my stream and they
end up going to you guys like by by
advocating for the same policies we
actually help both of our movements at
the same time he's describing something
right.
That is that is something he's
describing. He's not describing really
wanting to get people down into like
Marxist Leninist pipeline. He probably
thinks he's got a better way with like
some revisionist Marxism. He probably
thinks he's got some better way to go,
but he doesn't say that.
>> Why is it not the same on his side when
people have done this to my family?
>> Okay, so hold on. Let's go ahead and
follow that. So based off of that,
you're saying that he's creating the
stochastic permission structure through
which you can be doxed and harassed. And
since you're being doxed and harassed,
you have the right to dox him.
No, hold on. I don't care about me being
doctor. You're proving here. I barely
human you guys anyway. I don't care
about me. What I'm saying?
You saying that your friends don't just
let you do whatever the you want. They
call you out when you're doing something
stupid.
>> Call me out. Oh my god, you guys are so
entitled. It actually drives me insane.
But that's fine.
>> What? What?
Okay, that's crazy. Yeah, CALL ME OUT.
YOU'RE SO ENTITLED. Uh he just literally
wants the best for you. He's literally
just trying to tell you that you're like
things up right now. You're having a
crash out. You are manic. Chill the out,
man. You just got to chill the out.
You're You're in a total manic state
right now. It's [__] up.
It's
man. Uh
I'm I feel bad for Connor cuz Connor's
saying the right things. I wish I wish
Jesse had more friends like Connor.
Okay. And I also wish that they would
have stood with the spine Connor
standing with now a year ago.
All of this could have been avoided if
everybody stood on business and said,
"Hey, you're doxing people for no
reason. Can you show me evidence for
that?" No. Oh, well, I'm not going to
interact with you ever again unless you
do that. So, like, cop, you're you're
literally splitting away from everybody
who likes you and is is close to you. If
only. If only.
But nobody did it. Everybody supported
it. Everybody still hung around. total.
All of this is because he didn't have
people who would stand there and tell
him like, "No, I won't be around you if
you're going to do this."
>> Literally nobody.
>> I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I think you're
doing something cringe and gay. And I'm
I'm I'm entitled because I'm saying
you're doing something cringe and gay.
>> Yeah. Yes.
>> Oh, you. So, YOU DO WANT TO tongue up
your ass.
>> So, my Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, dude.
Conor's actually spitting today. He
picked it out immediately. I'm entitled
because I'm pointing out your bad
behavior. Yes. Uh-huh.
That's his homeland.
>> Yeah, dude. That's me. You totally
figured it out, bro. Um, not not not the
guy that's in here donating what was it,
$10,000 to streamers for the past 18
months to try to hold on friendships so
they go into Discords and talk about me
for a year. Not that guy. I'm the one
who wants the special treatment. Wasn't
your mod just in here earlier telling
you that people like Duby were cancer?
Maybe he wants to tongue up his ass,
too. Who's that stuck up loser? What was
his name? Fels. What' you call him?
>> The the mod who was just totally taking
Destiny's side. Dest said he just woke
up, but he was listening to the argument
with the mod. H be mean to fail runner.
Fellr runner likes you.
>> I don't know who else puts a tongue up
their ass. We don't want people that are
gossiping, calling the and taking part
actively in communities that have been
doxing, swatting, making bomb threats
with his family for the past two years.
I don't know who else is like a spoiled
like that.
>> Okay. Okay. My question [__]
>> Go ahead.
>> My simple question is is how is Doobie
running around all these VCs making the
argument that well according to Destiny
it should be okay to a log his family
members and them. How is that not also
creating an environment where crazies
can, you know, find or think that they
have some justification in doing this?
Because if you actually watch the clips
in their entirety, immediately after he
gets done saying that in descriptive
nature, he says, "I wish everybody would
stop doing this so we could return to
what Twitch and YouTube politics was 2
years ago where doxing was not something
that we would tolerate. It was a taboo."
>> Which side do you think contributes to
it, Connor?
>> Which side do I think contributes to the
normalization of doxing and harassment?
Let me let me ask.
>> Dude, you don't want Why would you ask
that question? You don't want to know
the answer to that question.
>> This question. If I were to drop all of
my aggression towards this these
communities, do you think that they
would still continue to dox, swat,
harass, inject themselves into my life
in as many ways as possible?
>> If you don't take responsibility and
accountability for the things you've
done wrong, then no, we'll still point
out the things you've done wrong. Will
we be as aggressive about it? I don't
know. It would depend on what you took
accountability for, what you took
responsibility for, right? what you made
amends for. But if you are just going to
keep crashing out and threatening
everybody around you, well, no, we're
not going to stop.
Dude, I've already said this multiple
times. If this guy could just admit his
wrongdoing, apologize to the people he's
done it to, try to make amends, I I
wouldn't like it cuz I I think he's like
he'sed up my life in some ways. Okay.
But I would let it go. I would feel
compelled to let it go if he truly tried
to turn over another leaf. But I I've
never se I've never seen any propensity
for that from him whatsoever. I've never
seen any indication that that's
something that would even cross his
mind. And again, the I've said this
repeatedly through all of the Destiny
stuff, including Dan going on a stream
and calling me a repeatedly. The
solution to this, the response to this
is just content. I will keep making
content on these crashes. I will keep
documenting this. I will always be here
to respond. And if you want to actually
escalate this to a place where I can't,
that'll require drastic action on your
part.
But the response is never to dox, to
harass, to do anything in real life. It
is just to document and respond.
Document and respond. Document and
respond.
And eventually we win.
That's the solution. That's what we're
doing. That's how we win.
>> I think yes.
>> Okay. And if they were to stop, do you
think that I would be for months, years
after be like, "Guys, we still got to go
after we got to get this guy. We got to
fuck." Do you think that I would
continue on? No. If they were to stop,
okay, so it's them. I don't know why
you're making this a both sides thing.
Again, if he wants to attach this to
Kiwi Farms, which he always does, right?
The Kiwi Farm stuff was in full swing
before any of the got leaked that made
me dislike this person, that made me
want to do content negatively about this
person. Okay. All the Kiwi Farms
harassment against him and against the
people around him was in full swing
before Queen or me got involved at all.
Before anybody got involved at all,
>> that's not my fault. You cannot blame me
for that. It's them. You understand?
>> Because I can articulate this because
you are engaged in total warfare. You
are going scorched earth. If we were to
analogize this to Vietnam, you are
dropping Napom. You're burning thatched
houses. You're executing civilians who
are sympathetic to Viet.
>> Hold on. What is the most scorched earth
thing that I've done?
>> Sports Batman. And
>> I wish I lived I wish I could live for
myself.
>> I wish I wish I lived in a world where
that was like the scorched earth because
holy that sounds like heaven to me.
>> I can't believe
>> this guy legitimately thinks that
because he gets like punched in the
face, he's allowed to like slap somebody
random and unrelated. like not even
unrelated, just somebody who like shares
the same political affiliation or
something. But it's like there's a
behavior happening to you that I
disagree with. Like Destiny has had
people like the cops show up to his
place, right?
I could disagree with those behaviors
like people trying to invoke some sort
of real world harm or trying to swat
him, trying to dox people around him. I
disavow all of that. But that doesn't
mean like that the fact that that
happens to you is not a reason that you
can go after me in some similar fashion,
right? It's It's wild. I just don't get
it. I I'm not talking about morally
justified. I'm just saying that your
portrayal of this is scorched earth.
When I have a community of people who
are weaponizing mentally ill women to
try to destroy my life in court, you're
like the worst THING EVER. DESTINY,
YOU'RE GOING SCORCHED EARTH CUZ YOU a
few of the most active members OF THESE
COMMUNITIES. DESTINY SCORCH. By the way,
just not even the most active members.
You just you like literally with e with
esports Batman and Supreme. I feel like
it's just because they were people he
like had as active parts of his
community before.
I I actually don't think it has to do
with how active they were. I think they
were in his community and he thinks it's
a betrayal and that's why he went after
them. What has happened to any of these
people? Has anything have anybody been
swatted? Has anybody shown up at any
other places work? Has anybody sued any
of these people? Has anything happened
to any of these people?
>> Uh here's here's one person who's
saying, "Yeah, this did happen to me."
This is one person who you have who you
part who you've participated in
harassment campaigns against. By the
way, I've also like I watched the
Anavore streams. I feel guilt for that.
Like when I when I see the system I
participated in, right? I watched the
Anavore streams. I thought that was
funny. It was psychotic. Okay. I just
didn't I didn't step back and understand
what was going on. And now I do see it.
It's like, dude, it's it's actually
pretty crazy.
>> I'll ask you a question. Was it moral or
just to do what you did?
>> Yeah, I would say so. Yeah. Self-defense
and accountability.
>> If doesn't like the idea, if the idea
doesn't like the idea that him running
around saying insane about me 24/7 all
this time, if he thinks that his real
life name being attached to that would
make him act significantly different,
maybe he should reconsider the things
that he says or does. The reason why
when I post stuff, I post it on my name
in my chat under my account IS BECAUSE I
WILL TAKE ACCOUNTABILITY for the things
that I say. Easy. Full stop. You know my
full name. You know my address because
Pixie loves to over it every two weeks
at a court filing. So if you want to
talk to me or do anything to me, YOU CAN
SHUT MY CAR. BUT LORD DELA gave you the
Florida to take the elevator up on.
Meanwhile, Dubie wants to run around and
talk the weirdest about me 247 over his
mountains of child that he claims he's
hoarding for the FBI. He was me every
single day. He's like, "Well, I do."
That is not true. Doobie is a good
person.
I'm not going to say I'm a good person,
but I'm certainly nothing like Destiny.
Okay? They want to make it the same
because they want to normalize his
disgusting behavior. We will not let
that happen. No thank you. No thank you.
You're gross. We don't want to be like
you. Don't make us the same. We are not
the same.
>> Do this honestly. Nobody should know.
And if people even knew my name, they
would come to my family. Maybe that's an
indictment on his behavior more than
mine.
>> Okay. So to be So let let's go for
wicked. So let's ignore Doobie for a
second. Esports Batman gave legal
consultation to Jtock, one of your
principled haters in the nexus of your
whatever you want to call it, your f
your haters, your snarkers. So, in your
mind, doxing him was justified.
>> When you say legal console, what do you
mean?
>> Was wasn't uh his crime or alleged crime
giving legalistic feedback to JTO in
reference to your court case?
>> Essports Batman credentials himself as a
lawyer and is literally creating a
permission structure in their discord
for a way through which they can
misinterpret or whatever interpret,
however you want to call it, every court
filing I have. He's like their he's like
their on call legal guy. Anytime you
hear Dubbie or any other, like, oh,
lawyers told me this, they're talking
about esports Batman. I think if you're
going to put YOUR CREDENTIALS OUT THERE,
IF YOU'RE PUTTING if you're if somebody
thinks that I think that Kofka coming on
is a legal person or just stream and
this is who he is or whatever. I mean,
yeah. I mean, I think that I think it's
fair. There's a reason why, by the way,
most leaguers most lawyers are really
reluctant to show up and like give a
whole bunch of legal advice or go give a
whole bunch of stuff on [__] streams
or YouTube because when you cancel
yourself, that's kind of a thing. I well
I I think Destiny is more comparing
somebody like um like his former friend
who'd be a lawyer who works at like who
who could potentially work at like a big
law firm or want a future in politics.
People who like have a very pristine
like a need for a pristine future, they
might really avoid that. Some people are
like smaller town lawyers and they have
like a law firm they work at or maybe a
law firm that they're even a partner in,
but realistically like something like
internet drama isn't going to with them
like Nick Rakita, right? Nick Rakita
could have been a lawyer and stayed a
lawyer and done his little local law
practice and really all the internet
drama wouldn't have probably with that
that much. It's like unless they're
doing something improper, in which case
if they're doing something improper, the
solution isn't to dox them. The solution
would be to do something else, right? It
would be to like report them to an
authority if you thought they were doing
something improper if that's what you
thought. But obviously that's not what
Destiny thought cuz Destiny didn't go to
anybody. He just just wants to harass
people away from commenting the sick. I
will say there's a substantial
difference between Kafka uh coming on
and talking about like random Supreme
Court ruling and esports Batman being
the personal on call snarker lawyer to
give all the interpretations of all the
legal and the same service where people
are reaching out to and harassing
witnesses in my case. I think those are
substantially different
I'm going someplace. So So HFA has
talked about your court case on stream,
right?
>> Sure.
>> Okay. So since he's giving you feedback
in reference to your case the exact same
Connor. Yes. You're a genius. Yes. So he
should he should be right because he's
enabling the internet machine.
>> If I found out that Kofka was in a
server where they were trying to reach
out.
>> I don't want you to change it. I want
you to answer the question.
>> I'm not changing. I'm making it one to
one. I'm not watering it down like your
dumbass just did. If Kofa was
>> I need I need to give YOU ALL THE HOLD
ON. I NEED TO I NEED TO FRAME everything
so that I'm the perpetual victim.
Actually helping Pixie in any way is
evil. And as long as you think that and
when I when I wanted to reach out and
get Rose as a part of the case, that was
totally moral. And they are like forcing
a victim at gunpoint to testify. It's
soed up. Wait, Destiny, how did they
learn that she was like a victim of
trafficking? Oh, through the deposition.
Oh, so time flows one way and there was
nothing wrong with that. Okay, cool.
>> In a Discord server where people were
reaching out to and harassing uh family
and friends of of JTO or trying to
harass witnesses to bring the case and
Cockas in the back say like, "Oh, look
at these legal fun. Yeah, I think you
know this is actually fine. I think
actually this is totally purposeful."
Blah blah.
>> Show evidence of people harassing your
family. What the I'm the king of and
find out when the have I ever looked at
a situation like that and be like I
can't believe this guy did this thing
[__] recorded. Of course, I would
understand it. But for you to compare
Kafka coming onto my public stream and
like talking sometimes and now more
towards the end of the beginning about
court filings that's the same as esports
Batman who exists in a server where they
are reaching out to and harassing
[__] witnesses in my case and he's
sitting there creating the permission
structure for by credentiing himself a
lawyer and then giving [__]
>> Destiny has harassed actively witnesses
in his case. Just to be clear, like
Destiny has harassed witnesses in his
case. Absolutely. He has
>> feedback on everybody. You But I know in
your mind you're going to find a way to
make that equivalent. That's fine.
>> Uh well, okay. So, so hold on. So,
you've acknowledged descriptively while
adding 10,000 qualifiers that CFKA is
coming on in order to
>> Wait, hold on. Wait, real quick. You can
acknowledge this real quick. All the 10
qualif,000
qualifiers haven't even been litigated.
They're just your narrativization of
events. lay out how your arguments
follow from the logs you show.
He knows he can't do it. He knows that
when he goes to try to lay out this
narrative that he's painting of like
everybody's celebrating because like
family members were contacted or
something. When he lays this out
chronologically, he knows he can't
support the things he's saying. He knows
he's and he's spiraling because of it.
>> All the ones that apply to esports
Batman, right?
>> That okay. that he lives in a discord
server where people are harassing
witnesses in my case and then he's
giving legal cyber there, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. I I don't want to go down this
because then I have to bring up your
equivalent and then you have to tell me
how it's not equivalent.
>> So So equivalent?
>> Wouldn't Wouldn't it be attempting to
Rose?
>> Yes. Connor. Connor. Now ask him. Ask
him why he talks bros
>> after your homemade.
>> I'll articulate. You said what with an
exclamation point and a question mark. I
would like the opportunity to explain.
>> I know. I understand what you're saying.
I just have to catch up on I don't know
how mind you you are by the in your DMs.
Okay. So I understand what you're saying
now.
>> My question IS YOU THINK YOU ARE fully
>> you're fully you are. I'm sorry. So let
me just I I know exactly what you're
saying. You're saying that Rose, right?
WHY DID I WHY DID I want to find out who
Rose was? because she leaked her
homemade to the internet.
>> Do you think it's fair for me to want to
know who that person is?
>> Yes.
>> Do you think that that is at all
equivalent to them reaching out and
harassing a person because they're
trying to out of Don't you think it's
relevant to get her testimony on the
record for the case? You did before.
How did you learn that she was like a
that she was blackmailed into doing all
of this stuff? That's the claim she
made, right? Where did she make that
claim? How did you learn that?
>> Okay, hold on. We're we're going to do
an experiment in empathy and you need to
slow down a little bit. Okay. Do you
think that people could earnestly hate
you for the way that you've conducted
yourself on the internet for the past 3
to 5 years?
>> That has nothing to do with this. I'm
not answering.
>> That's a totally irrelevant question,
dude. Come on.
>> What the does that have to do with what
we're talking about here? Because it's
the motivations of the people. It's the
motivations of the people that you're
talking about.
>> No, I would say no. Connor, no. There is
no reason. No. Give me one. Name a
single bad thing I've done on the
internet in the past 5 years, Connor. I
infamously I am a kind and caring and
compassionate person. Infamously so.
>> Sorry. You fat. TELL ME WHAT. GIVE ME
ONE REASON.
>> CALL ME A FAT. YOU HAVEN'T LIFTED a
weight in five goddamn years. You piece
of Shut the [__]
you.
>> Tell me. I wouldn't be able to withstand
the pressure. Conor, tell me right now.
WHAT IS WHAT IS ONE VALID REASON why
these people could hate me for my
behavior the past 5 years? Tell me.
>> Well, hold on. Do you I'll give you the
general reasons for why people hate you.
I know. NUMBER ONE. NO. NO. YOU ASK. I'M
going to answer. You ask, I'm going to
answer. You ask, I'm going to answer.
So, how about how about that time? How
about that time that you posted uh a
Minecraft uh character destroying a holy
site in Islam? Do you think you got a
FEW TESTS FROM THAT?
>> NO MUSLIM. THAT WOULD EXPLAIN SO MUCH.
DON'T ISOLATE. Don't isolate. I'm ask I
asked you a question. Don't isolate. I
asked you a question. Do you think that
people could earnestly hate you? If you
already know your chronology of sins,
then you already know there's 10,000
reasons why people could earnestly hate
you. and wants you dead.
>> None of that has anything to do with
this situation at all.
>> So, so hold on. You think JTock,
Queenman, Esports Batman, they all hate
you for delusional or non-serious
reasons?
>> Yes.
>> Uh I Okay,
>> that's crazy.
>> Okay, dude.
>> That's why when I asked you for one, the
only thing you can name is the Cabba
Minecraft.
>> You know, you don't think that you're
come up with a dozen reasons to hate you
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD.
>> GIVE ME ONE. GIVE ME ONE FROM their
perspective. Go. I mean, you're just
like a liar. You're literally just a
lying scumbag. You people. You dropped
all your principles. You don't actually
believe in attribution of like
attribution of blame in terms of
communities on the internet. Right. The
entire CEO's manifesto was a lie.
What else? Uh, you totally
misrepresented and lied about the Anavar
situation and manipulated her into
taking your side so that Mr. Girl
wouldn't with you. Um, you ruined Mr.
Girl's career over him basically soul
raiding you. There's probably a lot
more. Like if I could think about it,
these would all be reasons to dislike
Destiny before even getting to the leaks
from January.
>> WELL, THEY THINK THAT YOU USE YOUR
SEXUAL POWER AND clout and influence and
money in order to mentally women. Give
me what example. Annavore.
Annavore reached out to me. Anavore
wanted to meet me for two or three
years. Is she more or less than Cherry?
Cherry's also
one time, by the way. How the [__] I I
don't want to hear this person reference
anybody.
>> How could there be any hatred of me when
I hooked up to this girl one time, by
the way, when she pursued me over and
over and over and over and over over
again? By the way, when there's not a
single example of me leveraging more
power dynamics to do anything to her, by
the way,
>> do you or do you not think that people
could rightfully criticize you for
repeatedly engaging with mentally ill
women?
Repeatedly engaging with mentally ill
women. If your first go-to example is
Anavoir, I just want to tell you in the
real world, I know you've been mind by
this online. Apparently, I'm the only
one that's touched grass before. Nobody
would give a about a 30-year-old woman
up with a 32year-old guy who goes online
to talk about him obsessively for the
next year and say, "Wow, that guy is a I
guess a horrible evil person."
>> So the answer is no. You you actually
you just like like So you actually don't
think it's a valid criticism to say
Steven has used money, power, clout, and
influence in order to routinely engage
in promiscuous behavior with mentally
ill women.
>> No, it's Dude, it's not even
If you believe if you I believe that you
are mind. Okay, that's fine. Connor, I
believe. No, I believe this is
>> like why is Destiny asking like this is
weird for Connor to say? Connor has said
this for the past two years like
consistently the same maybe more
consistently. That's been his argument
for the past two or three years
consistently with the Anavore stuff. Is
that a fair is that a fair assessment or
recollection of the Anavore stuff? A
32-y old man met up with a 30-year-old
woman. They had sex one time and then
the other person, the woman, obsessed
about the man for a year. Is that all it
is? I don't think that's fair at all.
You totally left out the part where you
called her a stalker to your audience
and then you started with her again and
then you basically were saying, "Well,
listen, I'll I'll fix the stalker memes
later and and we're still engaging in
this dynamic while your whole community
was calling her stalker and saying you'd
fix it later." And then I believe after
this when she wanted to prove that she
wasn't a stalker and that you were to
you were talking in the background, you
threatened to leak her nudes if she
leaked your to show that you guys were
still together. I believe that's the
timeline and it's psychotic. Now if I
got the timeline off there, it is barely
off at all. Okay, that like you engaged
with her while people were harassing
her, while people were calling her a
stalker, and you knew how that made her
spiral, and you didn't care. That is a
that is a crazy situation. And then, by
the way, to cap it all off, you also put
her Kiwi Farms thread and directed
people to her to it in your public chat
like with thousands of people in it.
>> I final
since I've known you.
>> You can believe that. That's fine. Are
there any other things you want to go
over? Cuz this is this is probably done.
>> Okay. Well, no. If you if you got to go,
dude, I'm not doing this thing. I'm not
doing this thing where you pretend.
Yeah. See, this is so [__] we got to
talk. No, no, no. This is gay. And DG,
take this clip. Take it back to your
dad. He wants to go off and watch video
games. He wants to go halfass watch. He
listen.
It's not the best rant, but it's like
Conor's got an A for effort here, okay?
It's not the It's not He's not talking
the best, but it's like an A for effort
right now. Okay, we love We love Conor.
>> He wants to go half ass do tepid
commentary. Get the out of here. He
doesn't have anything better to do. He
has nothing better to do. Get the out of
here.
That that was that was the weakest that
was the weakest that's ever happened.
>> So, we'll go over to the Russell search
logs here. Okay, we read through some of
these. Just a heads up, I do not support
anyone going after Conor's family, but
since Connor is defending people who are
making arguments about going after
against against my act on that, uh if
someone did go after Connor's family, I
think they could see that as fully
justified. By the way, that's not true.
He's literally saying it's wrong. He's
not advocating for it, but Destiny just
doesn't get it. Des refuses to get it.
The content changes.
>> Guys, Stardust, am I known?
>> I got limited time. So, Stardust wants
to come in. I want her to say whatever
she wants to say. Does Destiny want to
come in or is he just talking [__] in
your DM?
>> I don't know. Okay, Destiny. Um,
>> yeah. Why are you dying a few nights ago
that Wick was doxed in that server by
somebody posting his
>> Wick? You can verify this.
>> By the way, can you check your DMs and
verify what I just said? Does it look
like I'm lying about the
characterization of those?
>> Uh, give me a second.
Uh, yeah. Yeah, you said most of the
claims in that stream were
>> uh I don't think any of these people are
or whatever. Um uh I'm in that Snark
left server. It's absolutely not a
singing server. Um read them out loud,
but yeah. Yeah. Now this guy's but yeah.
So you were What are you talking about?
>> I just I just repeated all that when I
was there. I didn't say any of that
[__]
>> This is I wouldn't be shocked if this
was um from Dan. Dan was like reaching
out to a bunch of people he knew was in
the ser were in the server
>> and when you guys made the shock I DM
didn't I didn't the moment that they
said this.
>> Okay. So that last message is that one
user was banned. It was from the PV
filing last September that Hassan showed
on stream where people isn't that what
you said to me. Was that what was posted
in that?
>> That's my That's my understanding. Yes.
And I told No, what I saw was not the PV
docs. I want
>> Oh, I don't know. So So again,
here
I saw
it from there.
>> I'm I'm still upset that you called me
[__] fat even though you don't lift
weights. I'm still upset about that.
>> So again, I assume So I have the same
image. I know that it was like I know
what your shirt was. I don't know if I'm
going to say that, but I haven't se I
haven't seen any of it, right? Like but
you but you can verify that when they
look like you're defending it.
>> Hold on. What I was defending is what
I've seen. Hold on. So Destiny, can you
tell me right now? Destiny, can you tell
me right?
>> I've seen it. I'm not sure how different
it is from the uh the PV stuff. It is
different, but I'm not sure how
different
>> now that nobody has ever posted in your
server.
>> I wouldn't defend it if I if somebody
had no what I was defending is what I've
seen in the server and what I've seen
allowed in the server. I have not seen
this allowed in the server. It is not a
doxing server. It is a flipping server.
So it's true that about a year ago
someone posted something. I don't agree
with that.
>> Keep filibustering.
>> You're okay. You're interrupting me. I'm
trying to [__] respond. Let me
respond and then you can go. It's fine.
Keep going. Go ahead.
>> Okay. Wait. Just to be clear. Just what?
>> Can we go one at a time? Stop. You
brought the name. Start with the Destiny
is correct that what you said in those
things was incorrect. It was wrong. It
was wrong. Now, I will agree with Dubbie
when it happened on stream. Doobie did
DM me and says, "I would never dox you.
If you want me to if you show me it, I
will find the people who did it and get
it removed and all that." And look, I
understand even you wick. I love you. I
know you're all mind raped. And I blame
myself for this lark. Okay, but Dy, I'm
sorry. Wick, you understand that when he
says that, he's just trying to
Dude, this guy just can't stop watching.
You can just tell the only thing he ever
watches is my stream. See you later,
Koko. Bye.
>> He just watches my stream all the time.
He just said he just started saying all
the things I say all the time.
>> Very, very, right?
Wait, if you tell me exactly where that
came from, you see how all these guys
the whole time saying that I am much
more likely to believe you because you
told me the truth and Dub lied to me. I
will say when Dub says that they're just
trying to find the leak.
Dub for the lie that Dub is trying to
spin right now in person. And again, the
reason why most of these won't talk to
me is because they can't spin these lies
in person because they're lying so much.
What Dub just said was he didn't know
what it was exactly. Now, I think
personally I think that would be fair.
That's not what Dubie said in that DM
though, was it? Doobie didn't say,
"Well, I don't know what was posted. I
don't know." Doobie lied and said that
was just where posted his TV blah blah.
How the like Dubbie might have been
wrong, but I don't think Dubbie was
in terms of like the magnitude of the
wrong that happened. I don't think
Dubbie is like very far off is is how I
would explain it. Did he even know that
unless he's seen something himself and
if he hadn't seen the actual docks which
you yourself say he hasn't it means he
got the talking point mentally into his
brain by justical or riitten house or
any of these other losers. That's
exactly what happened.
>> Okay. So
what I said what I what I said was the
what I saw was not the PV docs. And yes
in the DMs I was sent or the messages I
was sent I don't know if they're DMs.
Dubbie did say that it was a PV docs.
Now whether he lied or he was just
grossly wrong I can't say. I can't speak
to that.
>> I Okay. Where did you get that ide?
That's fine. So Wick, to be clear, when
you when they said this to you, I asked
you what it was, where it was, or who
said it, so that I could try to find
their history on the server to figure
out if it was in there, if the user was
in there, etc. Right. Or if I think I
see what server it was in, because we
know that the the leaks come from you,
why did you say it was PV?
>> Because that's what I can I'm not aware
of any stop talking. Stop talking. I can
tell you why. Okay. Because my only
understand my understanding is that
that's the only time information has
ever been put out. I'm not aware of any
dogs any other time ever. So when I was
told to put your reputation out there as
the runner of the largest apparently
plucking discord on the internet
and I know you're really I say please
stop talking to anything you're saying
you ramble on respond to it any of the
random [__] that you're [__] saying
rambling okay thank you so
>> keep rambling keep rambling keep
rambling keep okay thank you bye
>> with the word I'm totally fine with
showing those games like if you want to
like so you can see people see exactly
what I so or any of our games like I
don't have anything to hide in there so
um uh so what I said is
>> I haven't seen them post anything you're
doxing when you come up with
specifically memes about eating noodles
or something. I wouldn't tolerate people
doxing you. And then I said just figured
out where it came from. If you want to
know, right? Because at that point they
they were talking about it on the server
and they figured out that it was like I
posted in last September, right? And I
thought it was PB. That's what I
thought. But they didn't when they found
it, they didn't post it. They just
banned the person that did it, right?
When they found they didn't post it,
they banned the person that did it. My
understanding was it was that
>> so dooby you understand that Destiny's
argument is that you were doing this in
order to to kind of triangulate who is
leaking these things.
>> So this is why that doesn't make sense.
I'm not stupid, but this why that
doesn't make any sense. So, if I take a
screenshot of a Discord server and then
send it to you, unless my username is in
the side chat or I'm replying to
something, how the are we going to know
which user that came from?
>> Then why were you saying it was a PV
doc? You know,
>> I just told you.
>> Hey, everybody shut the up. So, I'm
going to make this point with Destiny
here because Destiny says, "Well, maybe
Connor's kids could get docks based off
of this rationale."
>> Whoa. I was not prescriptive. I know,
but I was just being descriptive, not
prescriptive. Conor,
>> but it doesn't make any sense in a
descriptive sense. So, it's pretty
obvious when you're not describing his
belief, right? You're not you're not
describing his belief. If you're not
saying what is the descriptive reality
that is led to by him advocating for
what he does, right? You're not doing
any of that. You're just making it up.
It's not attached to things he said.
>> Anyone have I know, but I'm just being
descriptive. Not prescriptive.
>> What are you being descriptive about?
>> This is why he's just crashing out,
right? He's just totally crashing out.
Destiny, go ahead.
>> I'm just saying that you're creating an
environment that could facilitate
harassment towards unrelated third
parties by
>> But I'm not for this environment. I've
criticized this environment. I'm
criticizing you for helping to foster
this environment.
>> I know. I know that you're not for you.
You're just describing it. And I'm just
describing your description. That's
>> correct. Correct. Correct. Correct. But
but you are actively engaged in doxing
people. We know that those people and
their families could get hurt as a
result of those reactions if you're not.
And I'm criticizing you for doing that.
So am I not trying to get away from that
environment?
>> No. You what a stupid you trying to get
away from it?
>> No, you stupid [__]
>> You probably disassociate yourself
completely from all these people if
you're a good faith actor. But seeing as
how this guy has only [__] you with
$5,000 over the past six months, I don't
know what your incentive is right now.
It's really weird by the way that I'm
arguing with two people that this weirdo
on disability child born consuming is
literally funding. is kind of hold test
everybody now dude they both took such
offense to that they both got so mad
about that both of those
show you want to be kind of if you don't
want to be associated with it you
wouldn't be associated with
>> No let's go ahead and do this let's see
if you're capable of being honest if
you're capable of being honest let's see
if you're capable of being honest let's
see if you're capable of being honest
the question completely can you steal
man can you steal man why Dubie said
that he uh used uh child abuse material
>> can you articulate it without trying to
cast the game as a pedoph
>> I don't think um I don't think Dub's on
disability I don't think disability goes
that hard that you can donate like
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars to people you know what I'm
saying I get a little bit but
>> ask you a question
>> just saying I don't think so
>> I'll answer if you answer that question
>> I yes I've seen casino and I love it
>> I would rather put my balls in the vice
that they use to pop that dude's eyes
out of his head and crush them then
steel man anything this
aging stalker has ever done no I'm not
going to steal being a [__]
perspectives. I'm not being to see
someone head on to it for a year. Like,
who the [__] you calling a pet?
>> Yeah. [__] you talking about?
>> Nope.
>> Dude. Dude, Connor just kicked Destiny.
Connor just kicked Destiny. Connor just
kicked Destiny. Okay, it's over.
>> Pop that eyes and crush them. Then steel
man anything this
stalker has ever done. No, I'm not going
to steal. I'm not being
>> held on to it for a year. Like, who the
[__] you going?
>> Removed. Removed. Notice how Destiny
gets more feminine and when he is
pressed. Yes. Yes, I do.
>> Hold on to it for a year. Like how? Why?
Where do you think I have any grand
stand calling anybody?
>> I already kicked him.
>> Oh, I'm sorry.
>> Oh, you so let me No, no, no. Wait. My
turn. Thank you.
>> He's lying.
>> Destiny is bigger, has more viewers, has
more money, has more clout, has more
influence. But if he was a peer, if he
was the same size, that's not how he
would behave. If he was asked to steal
manand somebody else's position and he
was a 50 viewer Andy or 150 viewer Andy
and Wick forced him to as a debate
moderator, he would steamman the other
person's position. And all he's trying
to do is say Doobie is my enemy right
now. So I'm going to go ahead and paint
him as a and I am incapable of
describing what he described in his
argumentation as once again.
>> Wow. Conor's like on the ball today.
Conor's like totally on the ball today.
Conor's like shockingly on the ball
today. It's out of this world.
>> I'll say this straight up. As Destiny's
fellow content creator, thank you for
the content. Love the content. Love the
money. Thanks for the donations. Thanks
for the 10,00k live. As your friend,
you're being a and I'm tired of it.